mon père et il est très beau ça
est ce qu'il est bon ici ce qu'il est
bon à google c'est pour me wade bottes
de cuir et ses bas de ma chaise ça
marchera pas énoncé les futurs grands
les questions en 4/3 de jean luc lemoine
et oui si vous nous rejoignez si vous ne
connaissez pas l'émission jean luc
s'intéresse à tout ce qui se passe en
off c'est à dire ce qu'on voit pendant
les pubs ce qu'on voit pas même pendant
les émissions et jean-luc décrypte tout
ça et aujourd'hui il m'a dit tout à
l'heure à la radio cyril j'ai dû très
très très très lourd c'est ça exactement
alors grâce à vous ma course est ce que
c'est une pression n'a pas beaucoup de
moi mais regardez vous allez voir un
j'en ai marre allez c'est parti
bonjour je m'appelle daniel géri là nous
l'a dit souvent que vous êtes ami depuis
plus de 15 ans donc je voulais savoir
est ce que c'est un bon ami ou une
petite crevure comme tous les gens du
showbiz fédéral fait que des amis
je vais être un peu le concept c'est pas
bon c'est parce que j'étais seul et non
mais c'est une excellente question que
vous posez la chaire daniel oui syrie
est un homme bien puisque je vous le
rappelle
il a recruté la majeure partie de ses
chroniqueurs à pôle emploi après est-ce
que c'est un bon ami j'ai longtemps cru
mais maintenant je peux la mire et non
comme dirait ma fille de 5 ans et un
gros caca
mais c'est horrible et vous le savez
peut-être pas je fais un spectacle
depuis janvier 2015
et depuis la première si rim annonce sa
venue chaque semaine pour finalement me
dire qui viendra semaine suivante je
fais entendez parler girl je me dis
qu'ils étaient débordés qu'ils avaient
beaucoup de responsabilités jeffrey
plaint d' excuses et un jour est un jour
janvier la wii tétouan à ce qu'un jour
ma je suis tombé sur ça
et
on adore tous les mois sur les voir le
spectacle ce fut génial le spectacle de
type himars un tipi
ok donc je résume un avis de 20 ans on
va pas le voir mais un petit pingouin
qui sortit sans qu on se précipite
je n'ai pas honte de le dire ça m'a fait
mal mais j'étais prêt à pardonner je
taperai pardonner et puis c'est passé
c'est non
l entrepôt à la croix trouvé pour
s'asseoir avec nous et on le retrouve
aux folies bergères j'allais voir le
spectacle savalli site
alors je suis désolé quand tu mens après
alan est un pingouin te dire que ton
amitié c'est de la merde tu sors j'ai
plus aucun ami dans l'équipe maintenant
que vous êtes mon ami non c'est fini
c'est fini je passe pas après un âne à
un paraguay vraiment déçus qui pendant
des années et fait en sorte de montrer
le meilleur de cyril comme quand il
mettait l'eau à la bouche au moment des
coming next
oui mais on va se retrouver dans un
instant aux émissions de fou gad elmaleh
kev adams
voilà gad elmaleh qui l'a dit si bien le
vendre leur âme sais c'est que ce soir
là les autres chroniqueurs était de dos
et vous savez pourquoi
et bien parce que cyril a fait une idée
de happening juste avant la prise
d'antenne ah oui allez-y je vous
retourne et je vous met un doigt dans le
cul tétreault
mais c'est plus sympa et sinon il est
sympa trop trop il a une facilité que
peu de gens dont il peut passer d'un
sujet à l'autre en un instant la
regarder il était agacé par quelqu'un et
d'un seul coup ce regard va croiser le
regard d'une des nouvelles de la saison
mondiale orange rouge jamais comme en
juillet tout en hiver les choses
et oui quand tu rentres dans l'équipe
celui de te montre son zizi
si tu me dis qu'il est beau battue reste
dans l'équipe c'est bizarre cette
obsession
en tout cas ça me fait une magnifique
transition pour parler de jean michel
maire
car une fois n'est pas coutume je
voudrais rendre hommage à mon camarade
qui ne dis pas que des grossièretés
attendant l'émission il fait d'autres
choses
messieurs dames contrairement aux idées
reçues et jean michel maire n'a pas que
des pubs à la bouche non il ne sent
parfois aussi des deux mauvais pas la
syrie s'est au début surtout avoir de
bébé chez le roi et qui tarde à renard
de baseball
la dotation d'accord le mec a fait ce
sweat il est quand même attaqué pourquoi
lauga il a mis une tête de renard une
batte de base ball de l'équipe
américaine de baseball est plus connue
s'appelle et fox jeux concerts rapport
avec ça franchement vous ça fait du bien
d'avoir quelqu'un qui a du bagout comme
ça qu'elle d'expérience puisque je peux
la triomphe modeste et il a raison
d'être modeste car après vérification il
ya les white sox de chicago
1 on vous regarde legault les red sox de
boston
ah oui hein mais en fait c'est pas des
renards ses chaussettes
alors pour des crétins comme nous qui
est que des soirées au baseball ça passe
le problème c'est quand vous avez un
nord américain comme gilbert rozon sur
le plateau oui lui tic un tout petit peu
plus ça se passait juste après le
triomphe modeste de jean michel maire
elle peut mettre des pv pour
déstabiliser c'est compliqué en même
temps c'est normal qu'ils connaissent
pas tous les équipes de baseball parce
que sa spécialité c'est quoi c'est les
médias
il connaît tout le monde vous êtes
méchant parce que c'était ta profession
c'est quoi la base journal journalistes
médias aussi bien sûr voilà est bien la
preuve c'est très impressionnant
je trouve que ces gens à bord s'échange
à mito qui
on s'appelle le comptoir mama pas le
contre était bon sur la france a un
incroyable talent non mais ça paie le
plus de choses
je prépare des trucs se fait peur c'est
un professionnel
bonjour je pensais mais on a aussi
isabelle morini bosc qui elle a une
autre particularité elle est polyglotte
la mecque les mots ya des femmes et ça
veut dire vous savez un brevet ou et
embrasse-moi ps - ce qui m'oblige à
reparler de jean michel maire
la transition était obligé après le
baseball
laisse-moi caravane nous allons parler
de son pendant chez nos jeunes sur cette
vague voilà on va parler de la lourdeur
du mois harcelée vita et regarder son
clip
enfin nous ont regardés son clip
non
je
et moi j'adore la musique de guitares et
elle est très très très jolie empêche
pas très joli thierry moreau qu'un pas
mais quand on voit sa gueule on comprend
qu'ils aiment mais il a changé là quand
même
il fait peur j'ai changé on dirait la
prof notre prof d'éducation manuelle et
technique oui monsieur foucart alors
j'ai bien dit dans cette rubrique un
petit conseil deux invités féminine
quand vous rentrez sur le plateau
surtout ne touchez pas jean-michel
n'arrive pas à gérer
c'était priscilla
moi
bien sûr
karajan
elle rapporté
pas possible d'un regard pareil mais
valenciennes il peut pas s'en empêcher
c'est pour ça qu'en septembre on a un
peu craint pour la sécurité d'erika
moulet arrive a rejoint cette année et
comme elle a oublié d'être vilaine et
bien évidemment ça crée des convoitises
d'après vous qui s'est précipité le
premier jean michel et ben non non et
ben non
allez-vous à la grande surprise de tirs
est mort au regard des normes
correction
eric à l'arrêt c'est vrai qu'elle est ma
langue a fourché
ces bombes actionnées vous c'est votre
style vous erika trop facile non mais
trop facile non mais c'est donc c'est
max il ou pas jusqu'à présent je trouve
plutôt sympathiques comme garçons vous
pourriez sortir avec lui ou pas moi non
non non non non non non à la terminer
définitivement terminée ça veut dire
qu'avant c'était vous souhaitiez pas si
mal au départ on n'était pas si mal ça
vaut mieux pas et erica est féru quoi
elle parle dans sa base
aujourd'hui pour jean-michel trop facile
jean-michel il aime gagner du challenge
le problème c'est qu'à force de dire à
thierry que c'était facile avec erika
bactérie s'est un peu emballé c'est
l'image la plus gênante du mois combien
on a jamais vu tirer comme ça c'est vrai
je viens d'y revenir y a que la pipe au
moment des cubes
sur lui ses beats audio est là il est
pas bien je l'apprenne de sa femme bon
au moins il a essayé pas sans aucun
mathieu de lambeaux c'est le match qu'il
fallait savoir s'ils ont l'oreille je
suis rentrée ils étaient ainsi près
normale michel a pris bonne place dans
l'émission quand même il faut le sar
battu de lambeaux a une tête à celle
fille c'est à dire que quel que soit son
attitude de départ des canes appareil
apparaît et change de tête poussent des
yeux et fait un sourire ni est figé
entre la statue de cire est un enfant du
village des damnés
regardez la transformation en temps réel
matière
c'est ben ali ce mec est formidable et
toujours la même pause et vous pouvez
vérifier
peu importe la personne à côté il fait
la même peut-être regarder avec vincent
nick lowe haye jeff pana clock m maitre
gims shy'm kenji ont dit non et même
rihanna
oui
mais fort heureusement que vous êtes
arrivé récemment passé des balles
recruteurs alors c'est arianna vous vous
rappelez incité lors de la fameuse
émission est battue avait été hypnotisé
et qu il convenait quitte à côté de
rihanna il nous avait tous beaucoup fait
rire ce que vous n'avez pas vu par
contre c'est qu'à un moment mathieu a vu
une jolie rouge sur le plateau n'en est
donc logiquement il s'est dit que en
plus de rihanna il avait aussi invité à
dell la chanteuse 1
et comme sa passion c'est les stéroïdes
et laissez-les fille il n'a pas pu s'en
empêcher
regardez bien la joie dans son égard à
la fin le mec depuis qui la touche pas à
mon poste et rend compte que des stars
la tranche 1 me roy aussi été notifiés
selon lui il croyait que tout le monde
était nu sur le plateau le problème
c'est que dans sa tête il voyait
vraiment tout jusqu'au moindre détail et
grâce à lui on a su qu'il y avait un
chanteur célèbre dans le public et en
direct
en fait c'est un chanteur qui avait fait
ça pour les jeunes regardez alors quand
on sait que c'est le cerveau de bertrand
qui associée cette image
madame je sais pas ce qui s'est passé
dans sa tête la pauvre et bien cette
dame
la city ben ça vous va très bien c'est
vraiment hors du cac la meilleure place
de la soirée ce soir là cet essai de
valérie bénaïm qui a passé sa soirée
essayé de rassurer bertrand et de
s'intéresser à lui quoi qu'ils disent
là il va bloquer sur notre écran géant
high et valérie va dire n'importe quoi
tout bertrand cas soit bon et beaucoup
de cars et dans les brancards et non il
ya beaucoup de carrés dans le grand
quart mais jamais de mary jane
maintenant on est même source est bien
derrière j'ai bon mais l'animal a
réponse à tout
surtout pas le contrarier quand ils sont
sous hypnose faut pas les contrarier
et là on entre la compassion le foutage
de gueule presse lui aurait dit je suis
anna dont elle leur dit si bien tu paie
des impôts c'est n'importe quoi
enfin bon en bref maintenant là
la reine du vent 7 ce mois-ci c'est
t'aidera enora qui a d'abord voulu
parler à matthieu delormeau problème il
était parti aux toilettes
il est beau et ça c'est gentil la suite
est plus compliqué il n'aura va essayer
de parler aux rédacteurs en chef
adjoints roma en gros un grand succès
gâteaux
ça la salamane iphone voilà en tout cas
si vous nous rejoignez merci d'être avec
nous on n'en dira est cassé c'est jean
luc lemoine et il sait pas bien là c'est
vrai que je suis moi c'est gilles verdez
passage admirer vit vraiment les skiffs
d'isabelle morini-bosc j'ai réfléchi au
début de la séquence pour vous prouver
qu'elle était concentré sur la
performance
puis
machete jeu
non non mais là là là vous faites exprès
arrêtez vous faites exprès vous a écrit
bien entendu avec le recul je ne sais
plus moi je veux pas être méchant je
vais pas fixer des indexées à ben oui
sans doute d'accord merci
non mais là il est 23h30 c'est t elle
déjà elle est déjà on a perdu là bas
j'étais juste pour elle c'est que vous
allez voir que là il faudrait pas la
garder trop longtemps après plus de deux
mois de présence dans notre équipe
matthieu delormeau poursuit son bizutage
et s'est assis sans le faire exprès sur
l'homme invisible
hier
non je plaisante je plaisante mathieu
battu et en fait malencontreusement
ranger son téléphone portable dans son
slip et il a reçu un appel non pendant
les pubs les chroniqueurs s'ennuie donc
on leur donne des ardoises pour qu'il
puisse dessiner un celi diot comme
exercice mais ça en dit long sur la
personnalité de chacun regardez j'ai
dessiné colis si un gars de ma ville
c'est quoi elle descendra du lycée pas
ses mots non elle dit de toi pas d'une
unique ou sans fil mais non il veut
démontrer
des mécontents et l'école dans l'équipe
tout le monde le sait mathieu est très
amoureux d'un garçon l'équipe de mathieu
oui la nuit j'en ai vu des mecs qui ce
qui fait mais laura fille mais c'est un
poème
là il va rejoindre cyril au poste de
présentateur et par mégarde il va faire
la boulette il va se regarder dans
l'écran de retour et en se voyant
mathieu voir une révélation
il n'a jamais rien vu d'aussi beau le
mec va littéralement bloqué avant de se
reprendre regarder je veux pas réagir
sur le bret d'accord est à des beautés
tout
ouais je regarde et vous à quoi bon
retour au bon vieux n'ont pas tarder à
me faire chier
s'il y avait une chose bien sûr laquelle
il faut pas plaisanter avec mathieu
c'est le physique là dessus mais les
ultras premier degré donc souvent il
oublie qu'il est en émission et fait des
commentaires comme madame michu devant
sa télé et en ce moment j'ai besoin de
perdre du poivre je suis à deux kilos de
mon poids de forme
70 818 beaucoup hein
beaucoup
travail oui les invités du moins ce sont
les comédiens de scènes de ménages
scènes de ménages qui ont apprécié leur
venue chez nous regardez juste la
différence au ce qu'ils disent et
comment ils vont s'aimer julien combes
et juste après
pas du tout par la cité par spa rien
rien ces incapables de dire un mot
quelqu'un je vous assure c'est une
cathédrale et les pauvres ils étaient
bloqués bah ouais voilà l'esprit c'était
pas par rapport à julien je pense alors
papa wemba c'est marrant de dire ça non
c'est le ça c'est bon on les invitera à
un titre ont d'ailleurs il est à moi le
français geoffroy mais son origine
tunisienne est aussi un peu vous dire
comment ils ont changé quand même l
approche de julien parce qu'il faut le
sas et c'est très compliqué de faire
semblant d'être content en télé il faut
des années pratique par exemple mathieu
delormeau
la syrie va le dire un mot gentil qui va
beaucoup déstabilisé
regardez bien sa tête le mec est pas
bien et regarder ensuite sa maîtrise au
moment de reprendre l'antenne
le renouveau le numéro 1 le champion du
monde alors c'est justement parce que je
veux voir parce qu'on a le décompte 1 on
est en direct un dans toujours en poste
depuis 4 heures 52 minutes l'écart et
l'espère j'espère sincèrement vous ne
voyez pas le temps pas si on roule
absolument faire cette émission avec
vous ce soir
cette émission en direct être avec vous
je sais qu'il y en a beaucoup qui sont
restés à la maison et j'espère vous
passer un bon moment avec n'oubliez pas
toujours un le hastag c'est que de là
vous rendez sénou des petits mots ou à
des gens que vous aimez ça nous fera
extrêmement plaisir et ça leur fera
plaisir
alors moi j'ai envie que vous êtes très
élégant merci trait dessus commande vous
rappelle rien sur moi trop trop trop
trop ça revient ça revient vous en
faites pas on est sous tension moi je
suis tranquille je suis passé non vous
revenez tout de suite
voilà lors du dernier prime
michael était très inquiet à l'idée
qu'on puisse détruire sa voiture
heureusement non c'est parce qu'ils sont
michel jean michel va essayer de le
rassurer
à sa façon tout en classe et en
distinction
tu licra sera
la direction plateau à jeudi chantage
relation tafer prend six mois
c'est que de l'amour bien sûr ce soir et
j'espère vraiment que tout le monde nous
regarde
saw 7 personnes voilà à s'échouer c'est
chaud mais ces gens le croient les et
jean luc lemoine a le droit de tout
faire il a le totem d'immunité il était
vrai il s'est même battu n'était pas
bien mais mes séries il est comme ça il
aime jouer avec ses chroniqueurs et les
maîtres comme il le dit lui-même dans
son langage fleuri en ra sera en
angoisse donc pour rendre hommage à
cyril et son oeuvre
je lance une nouvelle rubrique le 1 2 3
et 1 2 3 ra sera quoi tu sais quoi ces
lois de croire à travers diva j'adore
il est bien il est arrivé car il est
capable pour une séquence été cracké
et moi je suis pas là
on est lundi on est lundi me déguiser la
dégommer l'autre imagine vendredi de
coupe une jambe à 25 ans j'ai vécu les
appoints je roule une pelle morini bosc
a écrasé ma caisse
excellent je sais que certains ont été
choqués par la séquence de tir à l'arc
évidemment on ne le fait pas chez vous
non le fait que si vous avez jean michel
maire de portet dieu bénisse h et là je
ne veux pas être mais s'il était très
mal après cette séquence
alors là c'est que je vais montrer et
pas spécialement drôle mais elle est
importante pour que vous compreniez que
chez cyril derrière le masque du clown
ya aussi un homme là après avoir blessé
son ami mais s'il va se laisser
submerger par l'émotion et ça il
s'effondrer littéralement des images
poignantes
là ça
therrien pasqua sais rien mais vous
n'avez plus rien et c'est y est
volontaire c'est tout à votre soigner le
mec qui tirent ils pêchent dans la tête
de ce chroniqueur et après ils engagent
les autres alors une des grandes
nouveautés de touche pas à mon poste
cette année c'est le passage de
l'émission en direct le vendredi
ah oui julien courbet l'annoncé dans une
émission on va faire un petit jeu
deviner quel est le chroniqueur qui
n'est pas emballé par cette idée
1 à 10 il est habillé en rouge et la
bonne nouvelle c'est que la semaine
d'après donc dans quinze jours on
débarque en direct ou la vendée alors ça
vous pourrez alors
e
j'aurais pas à voir la vidéo donne et je
suis tout seul c'est tout seul alors il
n'a pas l'air convaincu mais il
s'appelle mais il faut la comprendre
entre ses émissions de radio on peut ces
compétitions de badminton et ses
rapports conjugaux le week-end
elle est au bout du rouleau mais
franchement quels sont au bout du
rouleau ça se voit à peine
montréal c'est grâce à ces problèmes
abordés je vous accueille et vous
accueille
parce que dans la catégorie chanteur de
l'année et c'est pas le van est aussi ce
type n'ont pas la race faire votre
avance 3 0 ne pas y aller
voilà
aller patiner avec vous bonjour je
m'appelle and la semaine dernière lors
d'une émission j'ai trouvé tous vos
chroniqueurs intelligent donc je voulais
savoir était-il douce sous hypnose